or you can post it on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash TV
hi everyone thanks for joining us today
my name is Serena Longo and on behalf of
Harvard bookstore I'm very pleased to
welcome you to our Friday forum with
Elisabeth Hinton presenting her new book
from the war on poverty to the war on
crime the making of mass incarceration
in America harvard book starts friday
foreign series takes place on friday
afternoons during the academic year as a
way to highlight books in a wide range
of scholarly fields our next and final
Friday forum of the season features
Malcolm K Sparrow presenting his new
book on policing reform handcuffed to
learn more about this and our many other
upcoming events visit us online at
Harvard comm or pick up a copy of our
event flyer next to the door on your way
out today's talk will conclude with some
time for your questions after which
we'll have a book signing right here at
this table we have copies of from the
war on poverty to the war on crime for
sale at the registers in the next room
we're very pleased to have c-span's book
TV here taping today's event when asking
questions in the Q&A please know that
you'll be recorded and please wait a
moment for the microphone to come to you
before asking your question as always
today's title is 20% off it's part of
how we say thanks for buying books from
Harvard bookstore your purchases support
this author series and ensure the future
of an independent bookstore so thank you
and finally just a quick reminder to
silence your cellphone's and so now I'm
very pleased to introduce today's
speaker Elizabeth Hinton is assistant
professor in the Department of History
and the Department of African and
African American Studies at Harvard
where her research focuses on poverty
and racial inequality in the twentieth
centuries she is co-editor of the book
the new black history revisiting the
second reconstruction and her essays and
articles has been published in the
Journal of American history the Journal
of urban history and time today she'll
be discussing her new book
from the war on poverty to the war on
crime the Guardian calls it a
magisterial new history and Brooklyn
magazine writes a clear-eyed and timely
book it traces the country's
cannibalistic prison industrial complex
back to the social welfare programs
created by Lyndon Johnson's war on
poverty this history is heartbreaking
but it is one that affects an enormous
percentage of the country read it and
vote we're so pleased to host its author
here at Harvard bookstore today please
join me in welcoming Elizabeth Hinton
[Applause]
thank you for that introduction and to
Harvard bookstore for hosting me and
including me as part of the Friday forum
series it's really an honor and a
privilege to be here and of course thank
you to all of you for coming out today I
know it is an incredibly busy time of
year but it's overwhelming to me to see
so many colleagues friends especially
students who I know are in them in the
midst of finals so so thank you for
coming out so this book is really the
first historical account of National
Crime Control Policy and it traces the
rise of mass incarceration in the United
States The Guardian in its review called
it a kind of a prequel or a prehistory
to some of the work Michelle Alexander
has done in her brown breaky in the new
Jim Crow and I really take that as a as
a compliment it's the product of a labor
of love and Department of Justice
records and the White House central
files of the Kennedy Johnson Nixon Ford
Carter and Reagan administration and
when I began this project a decade ago I
had to make the case to other African
American and historians as to why we
need to study crime control policy to
really kind of understand the
developments that happen in the
aftermath of the Civil of the Civil
Rights Movement and now especially in
the past two years these issues are kind
of at the forefront of national
conversations and discussions and really
at the center of at least my democratic
side the current political campaign so I
think that even the fact that you're all
here to hear about this topic really
shows that we've come over the course of
the time that I've done this research to
a new
kind of moment of where we are in terms
of coming to terms with these issues and
the consequences of the policy decisions
that have been made over the past
half-century in this country so the book
is is deeply rooted in archival
documents but today I thought I would
read from the epilogue which is called
reckoning with the war on crime because
I hope that you'll read the book
especially this summer it's good summer
reading it provides really the first
narrative account of the rise of mass
incarceration that we have but if you
don't get to read all the books or if
you only read part of the book I hope
that at least everyone will walk away
with some of the implications that it
took me a decade of research to come to
so I wanted to share some of these with
you and we can get into conversation
about the implications of the book
future directions for crime control
policies in criminal justice reform or
any kind of questions about the book
itself especially I would especially
welcome questions actually about the
Ford and Carter administration's because
there's been a lot of focus on my work
on the Johnson administration and kind
of rethinking the war on poverty and
rightfully so but Ford and Carter are
also really kind of important in setting
up the or laying the groundwork for the
kind of Crime Control and prison
infrastructure that Ronald Reagan
stepped into when he took office all
right
epilogue reckoning with the war on crime
the punitive transformation of domestic
policy in the late 20th century United
States followed a historical pattern in
the shadow of emancipation national
policymakers stopped at the extension of
formal equality and instead new criminal
laws and penal systems emerged in the
form of black codes and convict leasing
this is somatic criminalization and
incarceration of newly freed people and
their descendants shapes local and state
law enforcement practices from the
beginnings of reconstruction in 1865
until the start of the war on crime in
1965 after the dismantling of Jim Crow
as militarized police forces in a
criminal justice apparatus capable of
sustaining a new threshold of prisoners
took hold the developments of the
earlier period matured into a markedly
different approach to social control and
state authority merging equal
opportunity in crime control programs
within the Great Society satisfied
federal policymakers desire to expose
poor Americans to dominant values while
suppressing the groups of antisocial and
alienated black youth that officials
blame for incidents of collective
violence in the second half of the 1960s
national priorities increasingly shifted
from fighting black youth poverty to
fighting black youth crime for the
remainder of the decade as policymakers
introduced new patrol and surveillance
measures in targeted urban communities
in the absence of programs that provided
a concrete means to access decent
shelter education and employment poverty
and crime increased during the ensuing
15 years the national law enforcement
program that the crime control
strategies federal policymakers
developed proved to have the opposite
impact in the cities and neighborhoods
that they place under siege is one of
the most disturbing irony's in the
history of American domestic policy by
the time Ronald Reagan took office in
1981 african-americans have been had
become vulnerable on two fronts a
struggle against one another and a
struggle with the institutions and
policies that federal policymakers
developed to fight the war on crime
together the strategies at the core of
the national law enforcement program so
these are programs that I described in
the book so I hope that you'll read them
to learn about them in more detail but
these include pre-emptive patrols that
aim to catch robberies in progress sting
operations that created underground
economies juvenile delinquency policy
that criminalized generations of black
youth while decriminalizing their white
counterparts firearm sanctions that
brought federal law enforcement
authorities to the streets career
criminal court units that created an
expedited criminal justice system for
gang members and security programs that
made housing projects resemble detention
centers all of these hastened the trend
toward internal violence and
incarceration the process of
implementing these reggie's measures
eventually gave rise to historically
distinct carceral network composed of
punitive and social welfare institutions
with statistical discourses of black
criminality and pathological understand
of poverty serving as its intellectual
foundation in effect the federal
government's long mobilization of the
war on crime promoted a particular type
of social control one that signals at
the target arrests of racially
marginalized Americans in the subsequent
creation of new industries to support
this regime of control are among the
central characteristics of domestic
policy in the late 20th century the
decisions that policymakers and
officials acting in closed circles or as
part of a larger coalition made at the
highest levels of government had
immeasurable consequences for low-income
Americans and the nation however
unintended some of those choices may
have been may have been at different
times and in different political moments
ultimately however the bipartisan
consensus of policymakers fixated on the
policing of urban space and eventually
removing generations of young men and
women of color from their communities to
live inside prisons we can excuse a set
of actions and choices these historical
actors made as a product of their time
or as merely an electoral tactic but by
doing so we will continue to avoid
confronting legacies of enslavement that
still prevent the nation from fully
realizing the promise of its founding
principles until recently the
devastating outcomes of the war on crime
have gone relatively unnoticed for many
Americans it appeared as though
discrimination ended with the civil
rights movement and the United States
had moved beyond race-based systems of
exploitation alongside the tremendous
growth of American law enforcement over
the last 50 years a permit ability'
class surfaced and african-americans
assumes positions of power with greater
visibility from the rise of black mayors
in 1970s two displays of black wealth
for popular consumption to the
presidency of Barack Obama these
achievements promoted discourses of
cultural pathology and personal
responsibility even further making it
seem as though that as though the
systematic incarceration of entire
groups of racially marginalized citizens
reflected the natural order of things
political representation and the fact
that some black Americans have amassed
substantial wealth and capital do not
mean the historical race racism and
inequality has ended which I'm sure is
News 2 - many of you who are in this
room today african-americans grew more
affluent after 1965 by the end of the
20th century the net financial assets of
the highest fifth of black American
households were seven thousand four
hundred and forty eight dollars only
four hundred and forty eight dollars
above that of the lowest fifth of white
American households and the black middle
class has always been concentrated in
the public sphere in social services
where mobility is tied to the extent of
state spending on domestic programs in
celebrating the racial inclusion
championed by african-american activists
and their allies and classrooms across
the nation during Black History Month
every year the fact that many of the
critical reforms the post work of the
post-war period have been negated by
national crime control priorities
remains unrecognized for instance nine
years after the passage of the Voting
Rights Act the dawn of mass
incarceration the Supreme Court ruled it
constitutional to deny can convicted
felons the right to vote states have
consistently removed convicts from voter
rolls ever since the courts 1974
Richardson V Ramirez decision and today
nearly 6 million Americans most of whom
have already served their sentences are
deprived of the franchise as a result of
the racial disparities in American
policing and criminal justice practices
an estimated one out of thirteen African
Americans will not vote in the 2016
election due to a prior conviction
because of this felon disenfranchisement
and the set of peanut committed policies
behind it
a key civil rights gain of the 1960's
has come undone can go on and on to make
an already questionable situation worse
the US Census mainly counts people who
are incarcerated in state and federal
prisons as residents of the county where
they are serving time and sentence
counts in turn determine representation
so although rural areas are home to the
minority of the u.s. population they are
home to the majority of prisons in other
words urban Americans who tend to favor
Democrats lost representation because of
how solving disenfranchisement works and
rural districts that tend to favor
Republicans gained extra representation
because of how the prison system works
meanwhile as mobility remains stagnant
public schools and many urban
neighborhoods are more
segregated today than they were before
the civil rights movement
we must revisit the principles of
community representation and grassroots
empowerment that guided the early
development of the Great Society in
order to begin moving towards a more
equitable and just nation the Johnson
administration included grassroots
representatives and organizations in the
administration of social welfare
programs but this policy directive
proved to be fleeting promising
initiatives that had been designed by
grassroots organizations and that
received federal funding directly during
the first year of the war on poverty
were increasingly required to include
public officials and municipal
authorities and top-level positions
following the what the Watts uprising in
August 1965 before community action
programs were given a chance to work on
a wider level and for entire communities
rather than for individuals federal
policymakers decided to defund them and
switch course police forces took on a
more prominent role in urban life and in
social services in the Hong Kong
neighborhoods one can only imagine what
the United States might look like today
had the bipartisan political consensus
mobilized behind the principle of
maximum feasible participation that
feared the war on poverty's community
action programs with the same length and
level of commitment as they gave to the
war on crime out of their sentence that
society was becoming unraveled in the
context of civil rights and anti-war
protests federal policymakers held
african-americans accountable for the
turmoil and instability and took the
wrong policy turn opting to deploy
military police militarized police
forces in urban neighborhoods and to
build more prisons instead of seeking to
resolve the problems that caused the
unrest in the first place
once the Nixon administration moved to
terminate the Office of Economic
Opportunity and increasingly partnered
its activities with the law enforcement
assistance administration community
involvement in federal social programs
was largely relegated to the
law-enforcement realm even within the
crime control apparatus only about 2% of
grants the laa or the law enforcement
assistance administration awarded to
urban police departments went to tenant
patrols and other community-based
programs the White House from adjusted
Department were far more interest
in supporting measures that simulated
omnipresent patrol defensible space and
new law enforcement technologies in
low-income neighborhoods while fusing
police correction and anti delinquency
initiatives with social welfare programs
put bluntly due to its own shared set of
assumptions about race and its
unwillingness to disrupt the racial
hierarchies that have defined the social
political and economic relations of the
United States historically the
bipartisan consensus that launched the
peanut unitive intervention did not
believe that African Americans were
capable of governing themselves Nixon
expressed the sentiment overtly to his
chief of staff HR Haldeman there was
never in history been an adequate black
nation the president said and they are
the only race of which this is true and
I know that Nixon's comments to domestic
counsel John Ehrlichman and getting a
lot of press lately but I think that
this and a number of other quotes I have
in the book are even more kind of
telling about the the the racist intent
behind many of the policies of his
administration in a less conspicuous
form Jimmy Carter stressed grassroots
participation as a critical component of
his administration's punitive urban
program in authorities refused to fund
citizen groups such as the league to
improve the community in Chicago's
Robert Taylor homes which advocated
strategies that were very much in line
with the stated commitments of the
administration but sought to implement
those strategies without oversight from
police and public housing authorities
when Reagan took office the rhetoric of
community involvement vanished from the
domestic policy arena never to return
it's up to you especially my students to
change it not saying that we've been
talking about stemming from the punitive
shift in urban social programs during
the previous decade over the course of
the 1980's law enforcement officers came
to provide the primary and in some areas
the only public social services to
residents as the first line of contact
between government authorities and the
public police officers assumed various
duties depending on the groups of
citizens they are charged with
protecting throughout the twentieth
century and into the 21st police patrols
in white and middle-class communities
are expected to guard property from
outsiders in segregated low-income
communities on the other hand their task
is to search for suspects Andrew
offenders and potential offenders from
the streets disproportionate numbers of
African Americans received criminal
records and prison sentences as a result
of the differential approaches the
public safety that policymakers
enshrined in crime control legislation
by introducing greater numbers of mostly
white police officers in the nation's
most isolated urban areas federal
policymakers polarized both residents
and law enforcement authorities only 4%
of the sworn police officers who fought
the war on crime during the second half
of the 1960s and through the 1970s were
of African American descent a low figure
given the over representation of black
Americans both in national arrest rates
and inside the prison system James
Baldwin observed the impact of this
dynamic as early as 1961 as the students
in my urban inequality class know the
only way to police a ghetto is to be
oppressive Baldwin wrote and nobody
knows my name for black residents police
officers represented in Baldwin's words
the force of the white world and that
world's criminal profit and ease to keep
the black man corralled up in here in
its place like an occupying soldier in a
bitterly hostile country Baldwin went on
to observe the police officer face quote
daily and nightly the people who would
gladly see him dead and he knows that
with suspicion on both sides the problem
as Baldwin identified it lay not in the
individual policeman but in the systemic
forces that supported questionable and
sometimes deadly policing practices the
response of outside forces on the
segregated urban beat and the response
of residents to the presence of those
forces were the outcomes of both
historical developments and
socio-economic circumstance yet the
officer had few alternatives but to act
in the manner in which he or she or he
had been conditioned and trained more
than a half century after Baldwin's
insights aggressive policing practices
and mass incarceration have become the
foremost civil rights issue of our time
instead of being criminalized low income
citizens must be empowered to change
their own circumstances and must be
fully integrated into public
institutions at all
levels Crime Control is a local matter
residents and communities should be
responsible for keeping their own
communities safe various national
reforms such as police body cam nearly
continued the use of taxpayer dollars to
find new equipment for police forces a
process that began with the law
enforcement Assistance Act of 1965 the
militarization of American police and
the over policing of black neighborhoods
is a policy path that has consistently
proven highly unsuccessful as a crime
reduction strategy and fuels mass
incarceration and the racial disparities
within the nation's enormous carceral
complex now is the time to try new
strategies from residency requirements
for police to civilian review boards to
autonomous grassroots social programs to
job creation measures for the at-risk
groups who policymakers originally
labeled potential delinquent outside of
the service economy that will enable us
to finally confront finally the
entrenched systemic inequalities and
silver liberties violations that exist
within the criminal justice system as
well as the persistence of inequality in
the United States in August 2014 during
the series of demonstrations in Ferguson
Missouri images of law enforcement
authorities drawing m4 carbine rifles
and dropping tear gas bombs on
protesters and civilians alike shot too
much of the American public
Ferguson looks like a war zone prompting
new discussions about the nation's
punitive domestic policy priorities
among the general public scholars and
policymakers outraged over the deaths of
unarmed african-american citizens in a
general lack of police accountability
for those killed in the year at the
death of Michael Brown and the Ferguson
outbreak alone so during 2014 and I'm
going to say their names in tribute to
them this includes Edsel Ford Donte
Parker Akai Gurley Tamir rice laQuan
McDonald
Natasha McKenna Tony Robinson
Anthony Hill Meagan Hockaday Mya Hall
Walter Scott Freddie gray Alexia
Christian Icarus Randolph Sandra bland
Sam Dubois and Christian Taylor their
deaths have set a new climate for social
movements and federal actions the
conditions of the police encounters
ended in the loss of each of their lives
and the lives of thousands of other
innocent citizens that will never be
known would not have existed and could
have been entirely avoided had federally
had federal policymakers decided to
respond in a different way to the civil
rights movement and the enlightened
protests of the 1960s questions of
intent or the degree to which federal
policymakers foresaw the consequences of
the choices they made with respects
Orban social programs and black
communities are only relevant to a
certain extent the issue was to uncover
the series of decisions that made
contemporary mass incarceration possible
in order to discover our own actual
history the domestic policies at the
center of this book shaped the lives of
black women and men their families and
their communities and these policies
will shape life prospects for black
children and their children's children
even if the criminal justice system is
transformed once again ending the war on
drugs will not resolve the nation's
policing imprison problems even if all
the citizens serving time for drug
convictions were released and Obama some
of you may have heard just commuted to
sentences I think fifty-eight federal
prisoners serving time for drug offenses
which is a step in the right direction
but the United States would still be
home to the largest penal system in the
world if we only released those
incarcerated those placed behind bars
for drug offenses and as long as law
enforcement remains at the forefront of
domestic urban policy and remains
focused on young urban citizens of color
the regressive
impulses of the last last half-century
will continue to erode American
democracy
barring fundamental redistributed
changes at the national level the cycle
not of poverty but of racial
marginalization socio-economic isolation
and imprisonment is ever more likely to
repeat itself thank you
[Applause]
questions/comments
speech oh you use I've been reading your
book and it you often seem to suggest
that the remedies for racism involved
structural change maybe you could
elaborate on what you mean by that I
think in terms of if we want to think
about the the kind of root causes of
what we call crime and violence it
really stems from mass unemployment and
the the fact that the United States
economy transitions during during the
period where Johnson's calling the war
on crime from vibrant industrial
manufacturing sector to outsourcing much
of the flavor so in the communities
where police officers where the federal
government begins investing in
augmenting police force and simulated a
new level of police patrols these
communities are placed under
surveillance when really you know this
job creation program for as I as I
mentioned the epilogue mostly white
police officers is created we don't get
a job creation program to give
low-income people offer to new kinds of
opportunities so structural solutions in
terms of job creation in terms of
rethinking education systems in terms of
really investing in an education and
going beyond remedial programs that the
kind of meat of the war on poverty
really focused on equal opportunity
programs self-help programs as Johnson
officials called them and we're more
about providing training to low-income
Americans without necessarily thinking
about whether that job training would
could lead them to get a job after
they've completed you know the series of
training provided by war on pot with by
the war on poverty and other social
welfare programs
back here yeah yeah on pollution I'm
kind of market person you mentioned our
job acquirements and educational long
tenure but I consult a little bit about
the residency requirement yeah I mean
that that is you know fix that police
officers one way to approach a different
kind of rethinking Public Safety is to
have police thought police live in the
communities that they're responsible for
for keeping safe so instead of having
people come into a community that they
don't live in and police it and arrest
people instead of having people having
police officers live in the communities
that they're that they're meant to
protect and kind of serve different
types of functions this and in some ways
you know this might be romanticized view
it's been challenged but this kind of
returns to some of the earlier forms of
American policing that we think about
where police officers lived on the block
that they are responsible for keeping
safe this is before the era of really
really professional modernized forces
and I think that there is something you
have a different level of responsibility
and accountability to communities when
they're when you're policing your
neighbors essentially instead of people
who you don't really know or understand
yeah I remember I was wondering if you
could identify if you've looked at what
stabbed to change is legislative changes
would be needed because there's a lot of
protection that are inherent in the
systems of the police practices because
they're backed up by the laws in the
statute Massachusetts doesn't have a
death penalty but we have among the most
onerous restrictions right and I work
for the public defender agency and so
you see this on a daily base for the
criminalization of poverty with the fees
and other things so
do you see how you see that happening
where the statute change obviously in
addition to electing more progressive
people but how do you see that
fundamental legislative statute change
that is they're really protecting and
helping the district attorneys enforce
the laws and the police intern enforce
the laws and give them the power to
arrest and prosecute right I think
that's that's a fantastic question and
it kind of gets back it gets to the ways
in which I ended the book which is you
know trying to think about how to move
beyond the war on drugs you know part of
what gave rise in mass incarceration is
not just incarcerated people for really
minor offenses or or or drug things like
drug possession but the the kind of
extent of American punitive myth so I
believe there are currently 700,000
people serving life without parole
sentences which is as large as the
entire prison population in Japan
and so it accompanying these you know
gestures that we've made towards the
carcere 80 nonviolent drug offenders and
kind of rethinking the way that we've
prosecuted the war on drugs we also need
to think about the ways in which our
sentencing practices themselves the same
mass incarceration and and provisions
like three strikes laws like mandatory
minimum sentences etc I like the the the
widespread use of life without parole
sentences which some people view as
another form of the death penalty we
have to rethink the peen of the punitive
nosov American statutes if we want to
think about really really enacting
meaningful criminal justice reform and
then of course as as I mentioned you
know the first line of contact between
the the criminal justice institutions
and residents we also have to rethink
policing practices and if police are
meant to take on greater roles
especially social welfare roles in
communities as many forces have been
asked to do much the result of the
federal policies I explore in the book
then we also have to change incentives
within police departments so that police
are rewarded just as much for the kind
of community work that they do as they
are for apprehending suspects and
high-speed chases and and making and
meeting their arrest quotas etc so we
have to rethink the kind of our
draconian sentencing provisions and also
the kind of general police practices
that have been sustained for the past 50
years politics being a way to do that
because who you let's make the statutes
you see it as a viable of course I think
electoral politics is key I think you
know voting everybody should vote in
this election and we should vote for
lawmakers for politicians that we see
representing our own interest ment we
see kind of bringing forward the study
that we want to that we want to see but
but it's also you know and I hope that
you know new research and new
understandings of these issues
especially qualitative research can
really help us come to a new identify
new avenues for possible change yeah
yeah so I just wondering how much do you
believe that the changes in policing
that you that you've documented was
facilitated or opposed by the actual
communities I think there was the for
instance a book at the title account
river may be the new earth a black
leather majority right he talked about
you know the members of the community
desiring better policing better control
over what at the time was a larger
problem violence I'm just wondering with
your comment oh yeah I recently
co-authored an op-ed in The New York
Times with my my colleagues at Yale and
Cornell respectively vegetable weaver
Angela Lee Kohler Houseman that
addressed some of this issue because
similar arguments have been made in the
case of that book about the rise of the
Rockefeller drug laws and then the 94
crime bill Bill Clinton himself and
Hillary Clinton you know kind of
rationalized or supported the bill by
saying well this is when the cbc
advocated for this is what black
communities wanted and so this is kind
of a democratic process at work because
we're giving you know we're giving black
constituents what they're asking for but
the problem is in that narrative it
obscures the extent to which these calls
for greater protection these calls for
more for safety and communities were
also accompanied with critiques of
police brutality with calls for new
employment programs of calls for
rehabilitation which calls for crime for
prevention and despite you know these
kind of larger set of demands which
usually included you know a real
critique of police brutality and
aggressive law enforcement in in
low-income communities and that took
into account kind of the larger
socio-economic factors that contribute
to problems of crime and violence
policymakers only responded with with
with to to the demands for punitive
programs and so as we say in the op-ed
you know residents called for better
policing and politicians heard more
policing and that's what they that's
what they got and this is a historic
trend you know what the despite all of
the demands that that black activists
have made you know what they get what
they end up getting from the state tends
to be punitive programs law enforcement
programs crime control programs it would
publish in April to lead last month
yeah Jim I'll accept your invitation and
ask you to say something about Carter
because I'm so much scholarship has been
done on the recent situation on the 90s
in the role of the Clinton
administration and your work gives us
the 60s but tell us what happened to the
late seventies so so so one of the
things that that I argue in the book is
that you know that Carter the kind of
deregulation in the Carter
Administration the new the even stronger
partnerships that were forged between
the public and private sector especially
to solve social problems really begin to
take hold and new ways during the Carter
Administration so you know we can see
the transition to the kind of
deregulatory policies of the Reagan
administration emerging in the prior
administration and I think that Carter
doesn't necessarily discuss Carter in
that in that way so with cart you know
after Johnson the Nixon and Ford
administration's we don't get this kind
of rhetoric of community involvement
that I mentioned me in the in the
epilogue and kind of a focus on
addressing urban problems such as
employment education etc but what Carter
ends up doing and this this is
reflective of where kind of federal
priorities were and where funding had
been allocated by the timing took office
Youth Employment programs during his
administration for for black youth take
the form of installing security cameras
barbed wires bars on the windows extra
locks within housing projects so so in
this sense you know during the Carter
Administration that his major kind of
Youth Employment Program forces
african-american youth to become
complacent to a degree in their
surveillance and the criminalization of
their own communities and so that's kind
of a metaphor for the larger aspects and
limitations of domestic policy after
essentially a decade of of the war on
crime and and this new federal crime
control priority yeah you gene so of
moving forward where will we put Obama's
federal policy within the context of
chiraq
or any number of cities that have been
influenced or informed by Obama's
federal policy draw the connection
between Obama your analysis of his uh
approach to this and a Chicago or Philly
close your eyes picket City what would
you say that Obama's approach is to I'm
asking you know you're doing I don't
think that I I don't necessarily think
that I bama's approach has been as far
as I'm concerned or as far as I see it
my brother's keeper right but I mean
that is part of right right exactly
exactly so so again it's like this
rhetoric of trying to do something the
the kind of concrete so we get the
Ferguson report from the Department of
Justice which is which is a really I
think in some ways dealing with racism
and a level of extraction that is going
on in many majority black cities like
Ferguson where basically police as the
federal government said the Ferguson
Police Department isn't functioning or
wasn't functioning to keep citizens safe
but really is a collection agency where
it would you know kind of profile and
arrest people for failing to pay traffic
tickets so so literally the the Ferguson
Police Department when the city
transitioned to being majority black
kind of set off and it continues this
this historical trend of extraction so
the solution that we're getting to that
are body cams really that it that seems
to be the foremost reform that that that
we've gotten in terms of dealing with
the police and residents relation to
each other this is outside of you know
Obama releasing nonviolent drug
offenders the the senators can reform
acts that is currently before comment
Congress this attempted to D carcere
eight but the body cams I mean not only
does this directly benefit private
companies like taser which tragically
ironically taser was respond is you know
provides officers with some guns it
provides officers with instruments of
brutality and now they're profiting off
body cams which are supposed to hold
officers accountable but what they also
do is open up a whole new data
collection monster on top
of the other kind of criminal justice
data banks we have which will then
create new opportunities for private
sector and to kind of come in and
analyze that data and work with that
data again this is a band-aid to a
problem it does not solve the real root
causes of police community attention and
I think really Intel police departments
and the residents that they are
responsible for patrolling and survey
surveilling come are able to kind of fit
the table together where residents can
really have a voice and an input input
over the program and especially the
policing programs that are being
implemented in their communities body
cams are going to perhaps open up a
whole new level of issues and problems
that we that we can't even foresee for
taser though it continues to be good
business so so Johnson versus Obama
that's the harder question and what
about Nixon versus Obama the policies
the Hexen administration Nixon Richard
Nixon is far to the left of Obama in
many respect in fact in fact so I didn't
want to go there at that you're right
yeah Nixon was on domestic policy oh
yeah Geron buddy born he becomes a now
man mm-hmm so Johnson versus AIA Obama
what would you given his initiatives
domestic policy initiatives and our man
you know you see there are so you know
the war on poverty and and I am critical
of Johnson the war on poverty but that's
because one night you know that's our
job as historians to be critical of even
figures and and and programs that we
admire Johnson is a complicated figure
but the war on poverty and the policies
of administration the promise of the
principle of maximum feasible
participation is something that I think
we really really need to return to I
think that if we want to if we want to
think about a road map or a precedent
for policies moving forward then we need
to kind of look at some of the early
really you know the earlier ideas that
were that were emerging in the Kennedy
and the Johnson ministration I mean in
many senses Johnson just kind of took
the the urban programs the Kennedy
Kennedy administration had developed on
as an experimental level and implemented
them nationwide and so I think we're
turning to these to these principles of
empower
in communities to direct and shape the
programs and the resources that they
were receiving from the federal
government I think is really important
and I think that the that there is a
role for the federal government in
promoting greater opportunity for in
promoting and lessening inequality in
the United States and opening up new
dialogues to really address the
long-term consequences of racism
discrimination and class and equality in
the United States yeah what you're
saying about the other thing band-aid
band-aid really in any of this and I'm
just - your last point you you just
mentioned it but I'm wondering if there
is any possibility of moving forward
unless there is some kind of
acknowledgement that 1865 didn't end
everything it simply evolves after that
and that there has been no suggestion of
any sort of Truth and Reconciliation or
any kind of national conversation and
I'm wondering if where that might figure
into your excellent book I think it's I
think it's something that's completely
necessary and that's one of the things
that's been really exciting about kind
of finishing this research and and and
revising the book over the past year
when black lives matter and kind of the
the awareness and the coverage of what
has been going on really you know since
the mid-60s in low-income communities
and targeted african-american
communities is beginning to become part
of the national discussion I mean this
is the fact that Hillary Clinton talks
about making ending inequality the
mission of her presidency should be
should she become elected I think is
very promising so these these
conversations are opening up Harriet
Tubman is going to be on the $20 bill
the question is whether they will really
move beyond these conversations in this
room and elsewhere into concrete change
and kind of a growing awareness and a
change in consciousness about who gets
to be a citizen who doesn't who should
be included who shouldn't and what how
how much opportunities we should provide
to citizens who have been systematically
and historically excluded from access to
basic resources
including in the case of Flint water
that has been poisoned
Oh
amazing book incredible work and I
actually just wanted to ask the
historical question about the maximum
feasible participation argument how much
of the decline in the appeal of that
ideal do you think turns on the robust
participation of black power militants
in community control programs and in
community programming so somewhat you
know how much how little weight you put
on black powers insurgent into this
insurgency into this fear and - I mean
how yeah and this is you you can put on
this one this is difficult but it how
would you even suggest you know a
Johnson administration a Nixon
administration I would be capable of
navigating that dilemma right there's a
sore black militant organized control of
community control programs so I think I
think it's best that's an excellent
question and a different you're right a
difficult one to answer I mean I think
in terms of maximum feasible
participation you know Johnson almost
immediately after the federal government
begins funding these grassroots
organizations like the Woodlawn in
Chicago would law an organization in
Chicago which was involved with the with
the Gangster Disciples and gang
membership supposedly the question is
you know to what extent was as it was
presented to the Johnson administration
local officials really opposed this
because they didn't want to cede their
power to grasp its organization so
eventually as kind of a way to remedy
the situation Johnson not all means
institutionalized as many of the
programs the war on poverty but gives
local authorities new levels of
oversight and and power within these
community organizations like Woodlawn
you know local officials charged that
this was a kind of a voter registration
drive for the Democratic Party etc and
so Johnson increasingly backed off but I
think that even more and this is this is
a really central argument in the book
even more and involved with these
culture community control what really
kind of rocks Johnson and and Liv
all sympathizers further and further
away from these more transformative
notions of liberal reform are the
uprisings in the 60s beginning with with
Harlem in 64 Harlem Chicago Philadelphia
Brooklyn Rochester New York and that
continued to escalate every single year
as more and more resources are being
being allocated towards the war on crime
so you know Johnson Johnson and his
advisors debated the extent to which
these these uprisings these riots were
somehow political in nature they
recognized that issues of unemployment
that issues of lack of access to
education the same grievances that were
shared by the civil rights movement had
inspired you know these incidents of
collective urban violence so that but
yet you know instead of saying okay we
can respond to these issues with
actually you know we obviously haven't
gone far enough with maximum feasible
participation we haven't gone far enough
with the war on poverty maybe we really
do need a structural solutions if we
want to prevent future uprisings from
happening instead they back they back
away from war on poverty programs and
increasingly turned towards the war on
crime and really kind of merging the war
on poverty with the wann crime as a way
to suppress black militancy as a way to
suppress future uprisings yeah I didn't
answer it's like a question but that's
okay I can see later on Brandon is quite
getting around the black power biz yeah
for those of us that are old enough to
sort of have been around antiquity what
do you do with it did the black power
piece and then there was sort of the
corruption and disorganization but those
were hustling I'm old enough to remember
a lot of the community-based programs in
Philly and so you had an interesting
combination of the black Muslims Frank
Rizzo and the Angelo Bruno family all
operating in concert so in that context
where the narrative gets a little
stickier and more complicated because
there actually is corruption and
gangster stuff
yes because morning hand responds in
part to that because they had a couple
of case studies and I know the
Philadelphia came they were actually
pretty remarkable and in the case of
Woodlawn in Chicago you know it was
Arthur brazier the preacher right would
low honking so that was sort of a
faith-based program led by the churches
in the area what do we do with that
because here part of the difficulty is
that there's a there's a criminal
element at the left and if this is my
discussion with Brandon never quite knew
what to do with so the narrative you
know rightful you know black liberation
and then there's a third wrinkle which
is sort of the the the complicated
nature of what packs were black
militants which had a criminal wing to
it so what so my question is how do you
put that how do you filter that into
your analysis I'm trying to complicate
the analysis and I so honey how does one
filter that element into your analysis
well I mean by my initial thought when
you're talking about corruption
especially in that period and during the
Nixon administration that there's
corruption running through I mean
there's there hustling growing jobs
there's I mean the the ways in which
these programs are implemented on the
local level in some ways you know
there's corruption maybe within some of
the organizations that are getting
funded but there's corruption within the
ways in which the programs are even
selected to be funded and things like
that that is a problem with the kind of
bureaucracy in some ways that's created
we really see this corruption at the
highest levels taking off during the
Nixon administration so it's so there's
there's corruption you know at the
there's white-collar corruption there's
corruption amongst federal policymakers
in the ways in which these programs are
being allocated and so on that I
detailed look the Nixon administration
what we see actually in water day is um
is that very very much reflected in the
ways in which Nixon's friends and and
supporters get these newly available
Crime Control brands and similar things
happen with the war on poverty when when
when when the federal government
introduces and begins funding as we see
with the body cams and creates new
channels where funding is available then
groups will emerge to reap that the
problem is that
especially when you're dealing with
these kind of more transformative
programs with less oversight from from
state officials these programs are cut
off before they're really really given a
chance to work I think one one thing
that you're booked as well if we're
going to talk about corruption is you do
a good job of giving us an even-handed
analysis of you know Democrats and
Republicans and I just wanted to have
you comment a bit about what I perceive
to be an issue of disfranchisement in
terms of african-americans as a voting
bloc being left with just Democrats
being the representative and the
governance of things whether it's at the
local level or national level how has
that sort of contributed to an inability
on the part of ordinary citizens to
actually get their leaders to respond to
them in part because sometimes is this
issue of this clientele patron
relationship where they're being taken
as given as voters well that you know I
think for the last half century if not
before then I'm quite the Democratic
Party is really taking for granted
african-american voters Latino voters
and is able to kind of make these
rhetorical gestures without necessarily
enacting policies that really address
the issues that are most important to
them so we see this very much in you
know the Clinton ministration not only
with the crime bill which which kind of
exacerbated and already kind of bubbling
prison population the prison population
explodes as a result of this bill
introduces more police onto the streets
so we get that increases the death
penalty provisions for death penalty we
two years later we get his welfare
reform bill which is really I mean you
know Hillary will say in campaign
speeches that you know the black middle
class rose in the 90s and things like
that but the number of Americans living
in extreme
Burtie actually increased drastically
during the clinton administration so
part of it is and I think that again you
know new social movements in the
discussions that are being opened up by
groups like black lives matter are
really putting pressure on a Democratic
Party to address issues of you know
police community tensions in policing
educational disparities mass
incarceration re-entry programs that
will actually provide people with
housing and education and things like
that and it's up to us to keep that to
keep that pressure going I think and
this kind of gets to one of the
questions that Reverend Rivers raised
earlier perhaps because you know it
looks like unless there's a huge
surprise we're not going to get another
black president perhaps the next
president will be able to do especially
if it's someone in the Democratic Party
will be able to actually address racial
issues head-on in a way that Barack
Obama being the first black president
camp so I think I'm hopeful that we're
in were kind of coming to this moment of
change but as history shows us as the
civil rights movement shows us it's not
as if these changes are just going to
come out of the goodness of policymakers
harpes we have to keep the pressure on
them yeah click pop because there's also
the rhetoric of oh we're losing white
voters so what do we do which we know
also which some was what brought out the
Clinton triangulation sort of middle
ground type governance so is it
aren't you also worried that perhaps
even with all these pressures the
Democratic Party itself too is having to
face the decline in white voters and may
have to respond to that which then might
I think I think in so many ways I'm not
a political pundit so I can't you know
but I do think that these where we are
right now what we're seeing in terms of
the way that this election has unfolded
already reflects the fact that you know
we still remain in in many ways
inequality is widening income
disparities are widening we have not the
civil rights movement and the war on
poverty because it did not involve a
major structural transformation that's
never what Congress intended it to be we
are kind of dealing with the
consequences of this and the ways in
which race has kind of played as Du Bois
said it's like a logical wedge in
keeping people whose interests in many
ways are shared opposed to one another
we're seeing the long-term consequences
of that begin to play out and you know I
hope that as these come as we begin to
have these conversations and think about
the choices that we've made in terms of
domestic policy and begin to reckon with
our history that that perhaps new
coalition's and maybe even new political
parties will form out of this out of
this moment that were that we're in
right now one more okay
yeah last question um I'm wondering if
you could just theorize a little bit
okay I feel like I've been theorizing
present 12 in public hold okay okay how
do you get Trump supporters oh gosh
already supporters yeah to agree or
begin to see things the way that you say
because I think the big problem we've
been a lot of these discussions is that
um if you can forgive butter has become
a bit academic ooh right if we're not
able on to to get those who do not agree
with these positions right people who
believe that America's best days were
100 years ago we like to actually see
that there are changes that do need to
be made so how do we begin that process
and widening it the table that's a great
question it's a hard question I mean I
think that we are so divided
unfortunately as a nation and in all of
the different kind of classifications
and categories many of them most of them
arbitrary that we assigned to the other
two people that we don't know that
prevents us from being able to form
these kind of code
that you're suggesting laughs and so you
know part of it and if we think just
with the example of criminal justice
reform I think it's so important that
people who have who are who have been
incarcerated who are just coming out of
the prison system are at the forefront
of this movement I think that once
people begin to to know someone who is
incarcerated if they don't already and
begin to at you know interact with with
people and have dialogue with people
people's worldview people's opinions on
things begin to change and so I think
part of it is we are so segregated not
just by race but in this society that we
really need to begin to and I gosh I
sound kind of like what Hillary Clinton
said oh we need to become whole again in
a way but we need to see that we
actually have far more in common than we
do things that divide us the things that
divide us really don't matter and I
think you know it's difficult to think
about how in a large scale like
immediate way how to change that but I
think it does it does take exposure to
to communities and the people who you
thought acted a certain way you thought
were you know had a certain kind of
beliefs or behaved in a certain way to
see that actually they're not that
different than then you are and then
hopefully we can begin to actually act
as a collective instead of acting you
know as in our in our own self-interest
thanks for the question tough one all
right thanks
thanks everyone and thanks so much to
Elizabeth this was fantastic we have
books for sale the registers and we'll
just get all this out of the way and
have the signing right here thanks again
hopefully they have that really so much
yeah with navigation tricking the hearts
all around tricky fun